- [Kelly} So wait,
you're now doing a remake
of "The Wonder Years"?
- [Dule] Yes.
- Did you, Were you a fan of the original?
- I was a fan of the original.
I really enjoyed it.
You couldn't be a child of the '80s
and not be a fan of the original show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Who didn't have a
crush on Winnie Cooper?
- [Kelly] I never
stopped hearing her name.
- But I did also realize at that time
that I did not see myself
reflected in the show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And as much as I love this show,
and appreciate this show,
I didn't see myself.
- Yeah.
- Even as we were talking
about with the book
representation matters.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- It's empowering.
So when the opportunity came
up for me to do this show,
I wanted to jump at it.
I knew that Saladin Patterson
was the creator of the show,
who I'd known for years.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He's a dynamic writer.
And then, when I knew that EJ Williams
was gonna be a part of it,
and Saycon Sengbloh and Laura Kariuki.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I just thought it was
important to be able to
expand the lens.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- "The Wonder Years" belongs to all of us.
- "The Wonder Years" is not just
from a one group of people,
this is one story of "The Wonder Years".
I think the show can be
re-imagined in many different ways.
- Absolutely.
- You know, America is
a great melting pot,
and I think if we can show that more,
it can also help bridge gaps,
and unify people and
bring people together,
and that's one reason I
want to be a part of that
- 100% (audience applauds)